bonjour à celle de ceux qui nous
rejoignent maman j'ai arrêté l'avion se
penche ce mois-ci sur notre production
et consommation de viande consommation
qui a doublé en Europe depuis 1960 et
quintuplé dans le monde la viande est
devenue un marqueur de civilisation et
même un marqueur de virilité de vitalité
et de progrès social mais à l'heure de
l'urgence climatique le mythe du steak
frites tel que décrite par Roland Barthe
a dû Plon dans la halle car la viande
pèse lourd très lourd même dans nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre au
fait maman j'ai arrêté l'avion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un steak ce sont des centaines de litres
d'eau consommé et des kilos de CO2 et
miracle Litier et c'est loin d'être
neutre un tiers des émissions de carbone
sont liées à notre alimentation dont la
moitié est associée à notre consommation
de viande alors en quelques décennies
celle-ci a été multipliée par 5 vous
l'avez évoqué et juste un dernier
chiffre Daphné un menu végétarien fait
14 fois moins de carbone qu'un repas qui
contient du bœuf alors je vais vous
faire peur juste pour compléter et vous
donner un ordre de grandeur il faut
13500 litres d'eau pour un seul kilo de
viande soit environ 192 douches la
production de viande est donc très
gourmande dans nos alors que le pays est
à sec qu'on le veuille ou non il va
falloir modifier notre rapport au vivant
si l'on veut continuer à évoluer dans un
monde vivable je crois dans notre
agriculture j'ai montré qu'on puisse ans
se bat pour elle et on avance et je
crois ne souveraineté alimentaires mais
il est évident qu'on aura des
territoires qui va falloir reprocher
vers d'autres schémas de culture et
d'autres agricole qu'on a des
productions agricoles qu'on connaît dans
certains territoires qui vont sans doute
migrer vers d'autres territoires qu'il
n'est pratique pas aujourd'hui et qui va
falloir réinventer des modèles agricoles
dans d'autres territoires de notre
République c'est une évidence on l'a
entendu c'est la fin de l'abondance
alors que les nappes phréatiques sont
alors plus bas historiques que la France
connaît déjà des pénuries d'eau et que
l'on nous prédit un été plus aride que
jamais peut-on continuer à manger autant
de viande une filière si gourmande en
eau peut-elle continuer à produire à de
telles échelles quelles sont les
alternatives et comment limiter notre
consommation dans quelle proportion avec
quels effets sans faire bien sûr
insultes aux agriculteurs ni au boucher
français sachant que 80% des animaux que
nous consommons sont issus de l'élevage
intensif alors pour en débattre le
député renaissance de l'Entre-deux-Mers
éleveur et restaurateurs en Gironde
Pascal Lavergne le chef étoilé Thierry
Marx et l'agriculteur des députés
européens Europe écologies les verbes
Benoît Biteau bonjour et bienvenue à
tous les trois
installez-vous confortablement avant de
vous donner la parole nous allons partir
dans le Finistère allant d'une vase où
l'extension d'une méga porcherie
concentre toutes les tensions cette
ferme usine est passée de 9000 à 12000
bahts en 2017 malgré plusieurs victoires
devant le tribunal administratif non
suivi des faits les opposants ont décidé
de saisir cette fois la justice pénale
pour contester l'extension de cet
élevage pourtant validé par le préfet le
tout oppose est un sujet d'Alexis breton
et de jawhaarnati
[Musique]
à quelques dizaines de kilomètres de
Brest en Bretagne
nombreux sont les habitants de ce petit
village de 1400 âmes à se retrouver ce
soir-là à la salle des fêtes le sujet
est inflammable pollution et élevage
intensif de porc les gendarmes sont là
aussi et ils ont peut-être bien fait
devenir car soudain un petit groupe
arrive les éleveurs du coin et ce
n'était pas prévu
merci merci d'être venu nombreux ce soir
pour donc cette réunion publique
l'organisateur président de
l'Association de défense de
l'environnement local ne se démonte pas
donc notre secteur ici fait partie des
endroits où la concentration de gros
animaux d'élevage et extrêmement
importante entre 400 000 et 600 000
animaux élevés industriellement quand
même pour 48 000 habitants dans le
Finistère Nord les coupables désignés
vont rester debout au fond pendant toute
la Réunion petite pression mais les
habitants ne se laissent pas
impressionner non plus
votons et c'est nous qui payons les
impôts donc on a aussi le droit de vivre
dans un territoire
vivables si on devait manger tout le
porc produit sur l'enduite avec les
habitants dans une veste faudrait manger
18 ports par an ça fait par personne
bien sûr ça fait beaucoup
c'est niveau CM1 il faut faire des
calculs le mot de trop pour les éleveurs
[Musique]
à cause de la pollution certains
habitants ont porté plainte contre X
pour mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
cet éleveur qui habite le village se
sent visé vos chiffres
quand les diviseurs sont pas les mêmes
vaut quelques pourcentages vous savez
bien qu'ils ont été faits pour
stigmatiser pour pour montrer
la production et de la consommation et
qu'on mélange tout ça j'ai bien vu enfin
j'ai pas cours
il est à la tête d'une des plus grandes
porcheries bretonnes une exploitation
qui est devenue le symbole de ce qui se
passe partout en Bretagne
la première région agricole française
produit 60% des ports et 35% des
volailles du pays avec son cortège de
déjection animale de bactéries de
nitrates d'ammoniac la Bretagne est
aussi dévorée par la pollution
99% des rivières de la région sont
contaminés et c'est donc l'agriculture
et l'élevage intensifs qui sont pointés
du doigt un système dont la vocation est
de produire un maximum de viande à des
coûts les plus faibles possibles et tant
pis pour l'environnement à ce sujet deux
visions s'opposent pour les décrypter
nous avons mis face à face Agnès Lebrun
conseillère régional de Bretagne et
Nicolas Legendre journaliste au Monde et
spécialiste de la région c'est une
fierté
immense de la Bretagne parce que c'est
dans son ADN de savoir qu'elle peut être
un garde-manger parce que c'est une très
belle vocation pour faire cette
agriculture là il a fallu modifier les
écosystèmes et donc c'est l'intégralité
du vivant en Bretagne la faune et de la
flore sauvage qui a été impactée par ce
grand chambardement
[Musique]
nous sommes sur la Côte des Légendes le
littoral autour de l'andunvez est très
prise et les touristes
mais cet environnement sauvage aux
écosystèmes fragiles est en danger
voici la porcherie de la discorde qui se
trouve aux portes du village
en 2016 Philippe Bizien monsieur X a
agrandi son exploitation pour produire
plusieurs milliers de ports de plus par
an une extension que les défenseurs de
l'environnement souhaitent faire annuler
en justice
nous avons filmé ailleurs l'autre
réalité de l'élevage industriel et qu'il
n'a pas voulu nous montrer des animaux
sur caillebotis coupés de la nature et
enfermé dans des endroits sans lumière
naturelle
les hangars autrui entravaient 24 heures
sur 24 quand elles ont des petits
pas ici on est avec les ce qu'on appelle
nous les trigestantes c'est-à-dire c'est
des trucs qui vont avoir des des petits
porcelets ici c'est un élevage qui date
déjà de des années 70 un cochon il y
avait déjà mon grand-père mon père moi
je me suis installé en 97 aujourd'hui
c'est un élevage où il y a 850 de
reproducteurs ça donne à peu près 25
26000 cochons produits par an
26000 cochons et 60 tonnes d'excréments
et d'urine par jour
là c'est les tous les petits porcelets
qui ont été sevrés insupportables pour
les habitants ils accusent la ferme de
Philippe Bizien de contribuer à la
pollution de la région et de mettre leur
vie en danger evidemment nous on le
prend mal parce qu'on investit beaucoup
en temps en argent sur le fait que notre
élevage soit le plus
vertueux possible
on ressent un peu ça comme du
harcèlement
en Bretagne des élevages hors-sol comme
celui-ci il en existe plus de 1700
culturellement la Bretagne est agricole
et vous ne trouverez pas un Breton natif
dont les ascendants n'est pas un rapport
avec le monde agricole alors aujourd'hui
on a en Bretagne environ 110 millions
d'animaux d'élevage sachant qu'on est
3,3 millions d'humains la conséquence
c'est l'augmentation colossale des flux
de nitrates à partir des sols puis avec
leur ruissellement dans les cours d'eau
et les plans d'eau alors quelles
conséquence pour l'environnement
pas foule à 2 km de long d'une Vaise une
plage magnifique mais polluée par des
bactéries d'origine animale ce qui a
provoqué plusieurs fois sa fermeture
l'été dernier pour le plus grand malheur
de Laurent Lebert et de ses amis Hubert
et Christine cela même qui ont organisé
la réunion publique ah tu as vu ce sable
là qui c'est là que les gamins ils
viennent tous l'été c'est vrai que j'ai
appris à marcher
c'est là que j'ai appris à nager aussi
en ce qui me concerne je n'irai pas ici
à la plage avec mes petits-enfants parce
que c'est trop sale ça peut être
dangereux alors que moi petite je venais
ici sans aucun
risque il y avait plein d'animaux dans
le ruisseau là il y en a plus pour ça
absolument le problème vient de la
rivière il y a du billet qui est aspergé
sur les champs et dès qu'une pluie
survient des ruissellement vont finir
dans le point bas c'est à dire la
rivière et la rivière arrivant ici sur
la plage Shari à la fois donc des
alluvions et les bactéries des bactéries
comme Escherichia coli qui provoque
diarrhée vomissement et qui sont aussi
néfastes pour la biodiversité
la rivière qui se déverse ici le full
est jalonné par 31 fermes industrielles
qui ont le droit dépendre sur les champs
une partie des centaines de tonnes de
lisiers produits chaque jour le reste
être été chimiquement dans ces grandes
cuves un ciel ouvert
mais pour la mairie de l'andunvez aucun
problème la pollution vient d'ailleurs
pour nous livrer les coupables
l'adjointe au maire Rachel Jaouen nous a
donné rendez-vous sur une plage à la
baignade interdite depuis quatre ans
pour cause de contamination sévère aux
bactéries animales encore elle pour la
seconde l'un des élus chargés de la
gestion des eaux Lucien Kerebel qui est
aussi agriculteur on a fait des analyses
sur le l'intégralité du bassin versant
on a fait des points d'analyse
différents on ne détermine pas de
pollution réellement d'origine agricole
en revanche effectivement on a déterminé
des pollutions d'origine d'oiseaux de
mer
tout à fait on a des colonies qui
s'installent notamment à marée basse et
les analyses sont faites on va dire à
mi-marée donc potentiellement il y a un
lessivage de la plage qui font qu'on
détecte ce genre de d'excréments dans
les analyses les voilà les responsables
les méchants oiseaux qui défait comme
des malpolis sur nos plages depuis des
millénaires et qui tout à coup se
mettent à les polluer les écologistes
eux dénoncent ces analyses qui ne
seraient pas faites au bon moment quand
l'eau des champs fortement concentré en
bactéries et en nitrates ruisselle vers
les plages lors des pluies et il y a
aussi le précédent des algues vertes
provoquées par les nitrates depuis le
milieu des années 90 l'INRA l'Ifremer
l'Institut ne valorisation des algues
sont d'accord environ 95% des
surplus de nitrates dans les cours d'eau
bretonnes sont liés aux activités
agricoles et là c'est un consensus
scientifique qu'il y a un problème de
pollution en Bretagne c'est possible
mais un ne stigmatisons pas de ne
trouvons pas de bouc émissaire donc
c'est il ne faut pas imaginer que la
méchante Bretagne et les méchantes
agriculteurs bretons nécessairement
productivistes aurait un malin plaisir à
détruire ce qui fait la beauté de la
Bretagne aux yeux des touristes
madame la conseillère régionale
reconnaît qu'il est possible qu'il y ait
un problème de pollution c'est déjà ça
pourrait-il y avoir aussi un problème de
santé publique
dans le centre ville de Landunvez
Eric Le fin un retraité nous reçoit chez
lui il habite à quelques centaines de
mètres de la porcherie et il a peur pour
sa santé
je vais me faire un café
ici j'ai des filtres alors j'ai un
filtre à particules et j'ai un filtre à
charbon on ne voit que cette là tout est
fait avec ça le café le pastis aussi
d'ailleurs
comme Eric de nombreux habitants
refusent de boire l'eau du robinet ils
ne font pas confiance aux autorités
sanitaires qui la considère pourtant
comme potable
et une population qui part
très bien que l'eau soit au nord refuse
de la boire on
relève du libre choix de chacun mais
dans tous les cas aujourd'hui aucune
preuve scientifique n'est donnée que ces
eaux soient de mauvaise qualité
mais il n'y a pas que l'eau il y a l'air
aussi et là les données sont imparables
si les gens peuvent penser que
on est surpris on est autant pollué que
certaines villes
la seule porcherie du village rejette 33
tonnes d'ammoniac par an un gaz qui se
crée lors de la fermentation du lisier
un gaz responsable de la pollution de
l'air aux particules fines qui favorise
notamment certains cancers la Bretagne
en est la première région émettrice
il y a un certain nombre d'acteurs qui
disent que le modèle agricole dominant
en Bretagne n'est pas viable parce qu'il
a tendance globalement à épuiser les
sols à détériorer la qualité de l'eau et
à détériorer la qualité de l'air donc il
est difficilement soutenable ni d'un
point de vue environnemental écologique
ni d'un point de vue économique
[Musique]
fin de la réunion publique allant d'une
Vaise
si j'étais à votre place à chacun
d'entre vous
je serai contre mauvaise
tout ce qui a été dit a été transformé
ou déformé pour l'essentiel ou alors on
fait un lien entre des problématiques et
mon éleveur qui n'est à aucun moment à
bébé une petite demi-heure d'échange
stérile entre éleveur en colère et
habitants qui n'en peuvent plus on a
parlée par exemple si on prend des 33
tonnes d'ammoniaques en l'air je sais
que vous pouvez pas forcément le prêter
mais nous on peut pas l'ignorer
des positions irréconciliables avant
même que les éleveurs et leur soutien ne
sortent les éléments de langage sont ces
chlore tout débat la production
est en train de s'effondrer
elle est atteint pas de s'effondrer
demain
à l'agriculture ce qui est arrivé à
l'industrie il y a quelques années dans
20 ou 30 ans il sera trop tard de dire
qu'il va falloir
réagricoliser comment dirais-je la
France la souveraineté alimentaire
l'argument massue on mangerait américain
ça continue
lorsqu'on n'est pas capable de
s'autosuffire on doit importer alors ok
on va arrêter de produire en Bretagne et
on va importer du cochon de Chine c'est
génial on l'a fait pour le poulet de
Brésil
donc celui qui a veut faire une
dégustation à l'aveugle bienvenue et on
lui demandera à la fin ce qu'il en aura
pensé entre
1960 et 2004 le volume de production
agricole globale en France a doublé or
dans le même temps la population
française n'a pas doublé qu'est-ce qu'on
a fait de tous ces excédents
principalement on les a exportés
deux visions du monde agricole qui ne
sont pas près de se rapprocher
allant d'une vase le procureur vient
d'ouvrir une enquête à la suite de la
plainte contre X pour mise en danger de
la vie d'autrui
[Musique]
une réaction peut-être à ce que l'on
vient de voir vous êtes tous les deux
ingénieurs à Grenoble parce qu'elle
avait une
pas forcément le modèle d'agriculture
auquel j'aspire naturellement pour
autant la façon dont l'agriculture a été
conduite depuis les années 60 avec les
lois d'orientation célericulture où on a
dit aux agriculteurs produisaient on
s'occupera de revendre mais il faut
qu'on ait une alimentation pas chère
pour nos populations ça mène sans doute
à ce type d'excès aujourd'hui beaucoup
il voit un écossible caractérisé qui ça
aille aussi faire un tour en Chine ou là
vous avez vu on a des on a des
porcheries sur un seul niveau
immeubles de plusieurs étages
j'ai envie de dire qui sont encore pire
mais bon est-ce qu'on est aujourd'hui en
capacité de revenir un modèle
d'agriculture quasi vivrière comme celle
de moins de mes grands-parents le modèle
paysan qui avait une truie qui faisait
qu'il faisait des porcelets quelques
hommes pas autant qu'une truie dans une
Porsche rien du ciel comme ça et après
des porcelets qu'on élevé on faisait des
ports etc c'est plus du tout le modèle
de consommation donc il faut aussi que
le consommateur prennent sa part de
responsabilité dans le développement
d'une agriculture telle que celle qui
existe aujourd'hui parce que le
consommateur depuis bien longtemps il se
nourrit il mange en tout cas où il a un
apport énergétique aux protéique vous
nous direz tout à l'heure qu'il a un
apport protéique ça donne beaucoup plus
élevé que c'est que ces besoins j'en
conviens mais aujourd'hui il y a un
apport énergétique et protéique pour les
consommateurs qui se fait pour une
valeur moins cher moins élevée qui hier
vous croyez que ça se fait comment ça
j'entends bien mais à l'heure du
réchauffement climatique de
l'effondrement de la biodiversité et de
la pollution des eaux on l'a entendu 99
9% des cours d'eau et des nappes
phréatiques en Bretagne sont contaminées
par les pesticides 20% des Français
parce qu'elle avait une soit 12 millions
de personnes ont bu en 2021 de l'eau non
conforme est-ce que vous pensez vraiment
que ces élevages intensifs vont dans le
bon sens est-ce que ce modèle représente
un horizon viable écologiquement viable
pour rebondir sur ce que vient de dire
Pascal on peut pas contester que les
orientations ou les politiques publiques
agricoles pris ses 60 dernières années
ont conduit les agriculteurs vers sur ce
chemin-là pour autant et moi je mon père
faisait partie de cette génération là je
suis pas en train de chercher des têtes
à mettre sur le bio ou de chercher des
coupables moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
est-ce qu'on peut continuer comme ça et
moi je vais prendre l'angle économique
c'est à dire qu'on nous dit si on le
continue pas on va être obligé
d'importer mais on importe déjà c'est à
dire qu'aujourd'hui au motif qu'on veut
exporter des céréales du porc du bœuf on
importe du soja de d'Amérique latine et
donc tout ça participe effectivement à
accélérer le changement climatique il
est pas contestable que la concentration
des animaux
du méthane qui participe aussi à au
changement climatique et donc il faut
qu'on revisite tout ça et je reviens sur
la dimension économique donc aujourd'hui
on exporte mais on apporte beaucoup donc
est-ce qu'on doit continuer d'apporter
du soja ou est-ce qu'on doit au
contraire remobiliser nos surfaces
agricoles trouver d'autres équilibres de
production qui fait que on exportera
probablement beaucoup moins mais on
apportera moins et donc si on
relocalisait plutôt que de concentrer
des territoires sur des zones
spécialisées comme la Bretagne sur
l'élevage de porcs et de volailles qui
fait qu'on a un excellent structurel
d'azote qui fait que l'eau est polluée
et que ça coûte très cher pour la
dépolluer et à l'inverse par exemple sur
la bosse où il y a plus du tout
d'élevage mais où on a aussi un excédent
structurel d'azote lié à la production
d'azote de synthèse qui participent
aussi au changement climatique et bien
relocalisons un peu les productions
faisons moins d'élevage en Bretagne
ramenant de l'élevage dans la bosse
sortons de ces de ces excédents
structurels liés d'un côté à des
productions d'élevage de l'autre côté à
l'utilisation euh d'engrais de synthèse
et vous verrez que ça coûte beaucoup
moins cher alors je finis jusqu'en t'a
dire que on doit passer par là pour
atteindre des produits pas chers dans
l'assiette des des consommateurs qui
seraient les moins aisés ça veut dire
quoi ça ça veut dire que parce que on a
un revenu plus modeste on doit manger
des produits de piètre qualité c'est ça
que ça veut dire moi je
j'adhère pas ce truc là d'autant plus
que en vérité les produits réputés pas
cher coûte horriblement cher parce que
quand on regarde le poids de la
dépollution des solutions curatives
qu'on doit apporter pour réparer l'eau
ressources majeure René Dumont en 74
nous alerter déjà sur le fait que l'eau
était un produit extrêmement central et
extrêmement menacé sur la pollution de
l'air sur la réparation de la
biodiversité tout ça nous coûte
horriblement cher et ces produits
réputés pas cher qu'on trouve dans des
dans les rayons des grandes surfaces
sont en vérité horriblement cher quand
on y ados ses coûts externalisés et donc
si on si on payait la vérité sur ces
produits là c'est à dire le principe le
principe pollueur-payeur tout simplement
qui est qui siège d'ailleurs à la loi
sur l'eau ou à la directive cadres
européennes sur l'eau mais ces produits
serait juste hors de prix les seuls qui
sera accessibles à tous les
porte-monnaies ce serait les produits
bio Thierry Marx Laval bouffe c'est une
économie de renoncement c'est une
économie du renoncement c'est la théorie
du low cost qu'on a imposé un peu dans
les années 70 en gros vous renoncez à la
qualité et on échange de quoi on fait
des petits prix ce qui a amené
évidemment je suis assez d'accord une
agriculture très productiviste pour
descendre le prix et écraser les marges
de l'agriculteur c'est aller dans le mur
et aujourd'hui il faut aller contre ça
revenir dans l'économie du bon c'est
quoi un bon produit son impact social
son impact environnemental et son impact
nutritionnel c'est ça un bon produit
avant qu'il soit bio ou quoi que ce soit
et puis de regarder les choses en face
et nos modes de consommation arrêtons
mangeons mieux mangeons moins peut-être
passons du boeuf carotte aux carottes
pour moi c'est 80 mais il faut refaire
Dieu moi je crois à la polyculture je
crois une diversité moi je suis pas un
spécialiste de l'agriculture je suis un
consommateur mais du coupateur je suis
devenu un mangeur si on travaille avec
le scolaire très tôt sur réapprendre à
former à manger on aura moins de
consommateurs et on aura pas ça et
encore une fois je cette théorie du
renoncement liée au low cost est une
économie mortifère pour l'agriculture
mais pas que l'agriculture d'ailleurs
alors on a deux éleveurs et deux
agriculteurs parmi nous justement vous
êtes fils et petit-fils d'agriculteurs
de lobbito et vous avez hérité de la
ferme familiale en Charente-Maritime 255
hectares de maïs il a fallu que je fasse
le chèque alors vous avez fait le chèque
quoi qu'il en soit vous êtes passé d'un
modèle intensif à bout de souffle à une
ferme rentable sans l'amour ni pesticide
c'est donc possible et sans engrais de
synthèse c'est donc possible absolument
et c'est d'ailleurs ce que je voulais
démontrer c'est à dire que dans ma vie
professionnelle
avant de devenir paysan j'ai fait un peu
de recherche j'étais scientifique et
j'ai côtoyé des gens qui avaient réussi
cette transition et donc à un moment
donné quand mon père arrive à l'âge de
la retraite je dis ben je retrouve les
manches et je tente l'aventure je vis
c'est du passage à l'acte pour moi c'est
à dire que je suis passé de prescripteur
à
un acteur de terrain et ce que je
voulais précisément démontrer c'est
qu'en partant de là avec un très lourd
endettement parce que c'est souvent ce
qu'on nous met comme point de blocage
pour
pouvoir engager la transition donc à
partir de là avec un très fort
endettement je dis on y va on part sur
des logiques agroécologiques et on fait
la démonstration qu'en partant de là la
transition est possible et qu'en plus
elle permet d'apporter une réponse sur
le plan de l'écologie sur le plan de
l'économie parce que l'économie est très
est très pertinente et sur le plan
social parce que qu'est-ce qu'on
est heureux quand on fait les choses
autrement et rémunérateur et résilient
ça vous convainc ce modèle est-ce que
l'agroécologie parce qu'elle avait peut
nous nourrir moi je dis déjà il faut pas
opposer les modèles les uns aux autres
si Benoît Biteau a fait cette cette
transition en passant d'une génération à
l'autre c'est parce que voilà il avait
réfléchi à cette question je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de gens
qui sont dans cette réflexion évidemment
les agriculteurs ne sont pas
complètement sous à ce que ils entendent
du monde du monde extérieur beaucoup
s'interrogent je voudrais revenir sur
beaucoup s'interroge parce qu'elle avait
mais en réalité la France a perdu 100
000 agriculteurs en disant parmi eux
beaucoup d'éleveurs mais paradoxalement
la surface agricole est restée sable ce
qui veut dire quoi ça veut dire que la
taille des exploitations augmente alors
que ces effectifs se réduisent ça veut
dire concrètement que le marché se
concentre entre les mains de
quelques-uns au détriment des petites
exploitations on stigmatise beaucoup les
agriculteurs c'est pas agriculteurs qui
sont en cause c'est la gros business
c'est l'élevage intensif c'est les gros
exploitations c'est ça la réalité du
pourquoi les petites exploitations ne
sont pas reprises pourquoi les
exploitations ne sont pas reprises tout
simplement parce qu'elles laissent
suffisamment trop peu de marge trop peu
de revenus
ceux qui à ceux qui qui sera en capacité
de les reprendre enfin moi j'ai créé ma
propre exploitation moi-même mais enfin
j'en ai quand même bavé enfin c'est vous
vous avez un restaurant vous avez fait
déjà des cours particuliers votre modèle
il est très très résilient il est un peu
particulier mais sincèrement enfin moi
je je pense je pense que il faut des
modèles d'exploitation qui soit
peut-être moins spécialisé le modèle de
polyculture tel que celui qu'on avait
traditionnellement dans
l'Entre-Deux-Mers ou traditionnellement
en Gironde puisque c'est c'est de ce
département dont je suis l'élu il
n'existe plus et c'est dommage parce que
en fait ce que vous dites c'est que
l'élevage paysan est mise à mal par les
production industrielle il est pas mis à
mal par la production industrielle et
mise à mal par le fait que les
agriculteurs n'ont pas une rémunération
correcte des produits qu'ils mettent en
œuvre qu'il réalise donc à un moment
donné ça conduit à se spécialiser pour
pouvoir tirer les coûts de production
vers tirer les coûts de production vers
le bas et finalement on s'aperçoit qu'on
débouche sur des modèles qui
complètement industrialisés parce qu'il
y a une concentration des exploitations
bon voilà ça c'est le constat mais sur
ce que fait monsieur bidou vous
produisez quoi pour vous en sortir vous
parce que quelqu'un qui fait quoi la
solution alors moi ce que je produis je
suis en polyculture poly-élevage c'est à
dire que ma structure fait 208 hectares
exactement il y a 110 hectares de
prairies puisque moi j'élève des
herbivores et alors attendez écoutez
bien la révolution que je propose c'est
nourrir des herbivores avec de l'herbe
et il ne mange que ça c'est à dire que
je suis pas dépendant ni d’approduction
de maïs qui pose les problèmes qu'on
connaît sur la ressource en eau ça me
paraît je crois que c'est de l'actualité
un peu le l'irrégation du maïs et et
mais également effectivement du soja qui
vient qui vient de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique c'est-à-dire que en vérité
en France quand on enseigne un nectar de
maïs pour nourrir des animaux on crée
une dépendance d'un hectare de soja de
l'autre côté de l'Atlantique donc moi je
suis sorti de ce modèle là j’élève des
herbivores j'ai nourri avec de l'herbe
et donc j'ai créé les conditions pour
que ça fonctionne et bizarrement mon
rectangle d'herbe qui qui sert à nourrir
mes herbivores il est pas côté à la
Bourse de Chicago et donc
me donne une liberté économique qui est
formidable et et c'est ça la résilience
y compris sur le plan économique c'est
de retrouver de l'autonomie et donc je
produis de la viande de bovin de la
viande de chèvre un peu des chevreaux je
produis du lait de chèvre que je
transforme en produits laitiers vendu à
la ferme donc toutes mes productions
animales sont vendues à la ferme
quelques œufs de poules pondeuses j'ai
ensuite pour l'équilibre agronomique
c'est ces techniques je vais pas rentrer
dans mais j’élève aussi des bodets du
Poitou qui pâturent avec des chèvres et
des chevaux de traits qui pâture avec
des vaches mais ça c'est pour
l'équilibre de la prairies des prairies
et c'est là où je voulais en venir c'est
à dire que aujourd'hui où on montre
l'élevage comme un une activité qui
participe au changement climatique quand
cet élevage dans une approche globale
entretien des espaces préaux moi j'élève
sur une Réserve naturelle régionale mon
fils s'élève sur une réserve naturelle
nationale on préserve des espaces qui
sont remarquables en termes de capacité
à séquestrer des gaz à effet de serre et
donc c'est précisément parce qu'ils sont
entretenus par l'élevage qu'ils ont ces
facultés à séquestrer les gaz à effet de
serre et donc cet élevage ça peut en
choquer certains participent à
l'atténuation du changement climatique
le bilan carbone de ma structure
participe à la dénation du changement
climatique chez mon fils c'est pareil
donc voyez bien que que c'est
fondamental mais au-delà de ça c'est des
espaces qui hébergent de la biodiversité
absolument remarquable dans un contexte
où l'effondrement de la biodiversité
n'est plus à démontrer et on parle
beaucoup d'eau en ce moment c'est
précisément sur ces prairies qui sont
souvent des prérés résumés qu'on peut
stocker l'eau longtemps l'hiver au
printemps pour que cette eau et le temps
de remplir les nappes souterraines et
puis satisfaire parce que les nappes
souterraines sont remplies tous les
usages de l'eau que ce soit l'eau
potable que ce soit effectivement la
biodiversité ou pourquoi pas de l'eau
utilisée pour l'irrigation et donc vous
voyez bien que ça devient manichéen
entre élevé avec du maïs et du soja d'un
côté qui est le parfait cercle vicieux
sur le changement climatique sur la
biodiversité sur la santé et de l'autre
côté des éleveurs qui pratiquent un
élevage herbage avec des herbes qui
mange de l'herbe où là on prend soin de
la biodiversité on prend soin du climat
on prend soin de la santé c'est un
modèle indispensable il y va de leur
communiquement c'est pertinent parce que
les coûts de production sont très
faibles je défends vraiment cette
agriculture c'est vraiment mon mon cœur
de métier moi en tant que travailleur
pour la version je défends mais encore
une fois ce que je défends aussi c'est
qu'il y a un public en face et il faut
pas qu'il y ait un consommateur en face
il faut qu'il y ait un mangeur
aujourd'hui on a une France qui a sur
une fracture sociale extrêmement dure et
on a une alimentation à deux vitesses on
a une alimentation pour des gens qui
comprennent un peu ce qu'ils mangent et
qui ont un reste à vivre suffisant et
puis des gens qui n'ont pas un reste à
vivre suffisant et qui se contentent de
l'ultra transformé parce que le 10 du
mois on est à l'euro près donc il y a un
vrai un vrai travail à faire et un qui
est un travail politique au sens
étymologique du terme sur cette
problématique de la de l'alimentation au
globale pour parler du bon pour tous
mais si j'ai pas un public en face pour
comprendre ce type d'agriture que je
n'ai que des consommateurs qui achètent
à l'euro près c'est c'est un vrai débat
et à chaque fois qui écrase des marges
de l'agriculteur bah c'était
l'agriculture productiviste elle existe
parce que à Monday il y a un réseau de
distribution qui correspond à ça et
quand on fait une variable d'ajustement
du pouvoir d'achat sur l'alimentation
mais l'alimentation est pas un carburant
mettez dans votre voiture ça n'a rien à
voir c'est ça des conséquences sur
l'impact social et bien évidemment sur
l'impact santé des populations justement
ne faudrait-il pas fléchir les
subventions de la PAC vers
l'agroécologie et non pas vers
l'industrie il y a quand même une
orientation petit à petit qui est prise
par rapport à ça ok un plan il y a un
plan protéines oui les petits mais il
faut voir le chemin parcouru il reste
toujours du chemin à parcourir mais
voilà il faut mesurer le chemin qui est
parcouru malgré tout moi je crois
qu'effectivement tel que la décrit
Benoît Vito je suis ravi d'ailleurs
d'entendre de la part d'un élu
écologiste le discours qu'il a tenu par
rapport au bovins moi qui suis
uniquement éleveur bovin quand j'entends
ce que j'entends dans l'hémicycle et que
j'entends ici à LCP donc dans les dans
les locaux du Palais Bourbon que voilà
la part d'un de l'écologie ça me fait
quand même plaisir mais c'est pas la
même production
herbaget c'est c'est le modèle parfait
effectivement pour l'élevage bovins
viande il ne faut pas jeter le bébé avec
l'eau du bain en tout cas il faut pas
voilà non mais balancer nos bovins notre
élevage bovin tel qu'on le critique de
façon trop systématique trop rapide les
bovins ils empruntent quand même plein
la tête souvent Pascal la vérité la
viande c'est 5 kg de légumineuses
produits pour 1 kg de viande autrement
dit ne devrait-on pas libérer fissa de
la de la de l'espace agricole pour
nourrir non pas les bêtes mais les
humains 60% de nos terres en Europe
certes à nourrir le bétail on marche un
peu sur la tête non on est d'accord mais
enfin un petit remarque tout à l'heure
mais moi je mange pas que pour ingérer
des protéines et ingérer l'énergie je
mange aussi pour le plaisir pour du goût
pour une gastronomie voilà qui s'inscrit
dans l'histoire du patrimoine du
patrimoine français cette gastronomie
elle est aussi en capacité d'évoluer et
je pense pense que des grands chefs
comme comme Thierry Marx ont aussi entre
guillemets n'ont pas une part de
responsabilité mais en tout cas ce
centre peuvent se sentir investi d'une
mission pour pouvoir faire découvrir au
travers d'autres pratiques
gastronomiques faire découvrir des
choses voilà ça effectivement c'est
aussi un volet de l'histoire que je
pense qu'il faudra qu'il faudra intégrer
je réponds quand même j'insiste pour
pouvoir répondre sur les bovins les
bovins aujourd'hui tels qu'ils sont
élevés dans notre pays et en Europe ça
n'a rien à voir avec les filles de
l'autre que vous trouvez de l'autre côté
de l'Atlantique aujourd'hui nous pour
nous nous devons encore défendre le
modèle d'élevage bovins français qui
s'appuient principalement sur l'herbe
âgée qui valorise à la fois des
légumineuses qui fixent l'azote de l'air
et qui évite d'avoir recours à la
fertilisation à la fertilisation azotée
issue de la pétrochimie on doit revoir
les assolements on doit revoir tout ce
système prayrial de prairies naturelles
qui doivent intégrer des légumineuses
plusieurs plusieurs types de graminées
c'est aussi la diversité qui permettra
de maintenir l'élevage français une
vache dans une ferme usine sa peluche
une vache auprès sa fertilise
une vache auprès ça rend un service
également dans le cycle de l'eau ça rend
un service en termes de biodiversité en
fonction des milieux dans lequel elle
est là quand on parle du milieu poids de
vin il y a un certain équilibre de
biodiversité quand on est sur les
coteaux du cantalia encore un autre
système de biodiversité les bovins vous
savez c'est des ruminants ils ont un
système digestif bien particulier et ils
ont aussi leur rôle à jouer dans
l'équilibre dans l'équilibre agronomique
des sols et c'est pour ça que la non
spécialisation des bassins il faudrait
qu'on y revienne à des systèmes de
polyculturellevage qui permettent
effectivement d'allier une fertilisation
agronomique
issue de l'élevage plutôt que d'avoir
recours à de l'engrais à de l'engrais
chimique j'y crois aussi à ça mais voilà
on a été trop loin mais on va revenir un
peu en arrière mais ça les agriculteurs
ils ont entendu le message ils sont
prêts à le faire mais il faut leur
laisser du temps venons-en à la viande
de synthèse après les burgers végétaux
high tech on parle beaucoup ces temps-ci
de la viande cellulaire ou viande de
synthèse l'idée de mettre de la
technologie dans notre assiette est-elle
une bonne idée réponse dans le
climatoscope de Rafa Litier
alors est-ce que c'est une bonne idée
peut-être mais c'est clairement pas pour
le goût qu'on fait ça l'intérêt
principal de la viande artificielle
alors avant de venir à l'intérêt
peut-être que je peux définir ce que
c'est sa consiste non pas après lever de
la viande sur un animal vivant mais
juste après lever des cellules qu'on va
mettre en culture dans des dans des
incubateurs on va mélanger ça avec des
ingrédients qui vont bien et orienter
la fabrication d'être un petit veau le
voir courir dans le champ et quitte à ce
que la vache me foute un grand coup de
tête parce qu'il faut pas que je
m'approche du petit veau sincèrement je
trouve ça plus rigolo plus sympa
le seul intérêt de cette approche là
étant de fournir un apport en protéines
en évitant de tuer des animaux si on
croit les chiffres qui sont donnés par
par un des pionniers de la viande
vitraux c'est-à-dire qu'avec une vache
avec les cellules d'une seule bâche on
peut produire jusqu'à 175 millions de
steaks l'équivalent de 400.000 vaches
donc du point de la vache qui va à
l'abattoir la viande artificielle c'est
mieux ça c'est clair est-ce que du point
de vue écologique est-ce que franchement
c'est différent il faut bien se
représenter ce qu'est cette activité qui
est en train d'émerger c'est que c'est
une activité industrielle on va pas
fabriquer on va pas fabriquer de la
viande artificielle sur un coin de
paillasse dans un laboratoire familial
l'une des plus grosses entreprises qui
impliquait là-dedans est en train de
concevoir des bioréacteurs qui font 250
000 litres donc du coup on est vraiment
sur de l'industrie donc avec de la
machine donc avec des machines qui qui
consomment de l'énergie et donc du coup
qui qui vont envoyer du carbone dans le
dans l'atmosphère donc le l'intérêt
climatique ou écologique de la viande
artificielle n'est pas totalement avérée
d'autant plus que pour l'instant le
procédé personne de communique là-dessus
parce que tout le monde se tire un petit
peu la bourre il y a du secret
industriel derrière tout ça et il y a
pas d'évaluation indépendante sur ces
questions là alors
il y a eu au Sénat on a une réponse au
Sénat on voit encore une fois que c'est
pour nous couper du monde du vivant
justement le danger c'est la
manipulation des masses avec ça et on
voit bien que c'est porté 90 millions de
dollars ont été levés c'est plutôt sur
la Chine et d'avoir ces produits in
vitro qui sont battent du tout
environnementalement responsable vous
coupe du lien avec le vivant ce qui veut
dire que c'est dangereux
vous avez été le chef de fil de la
cuisine moléculaire vous êtes à la tête
d'un laboratoire de recherche qui vise à
améliorer le contenu nos assiettes
j'imagine que vous êtes penché sur la
question la viande cellulaire non avec
complètement c'est-à-dire qu'on a on a
vraiment regardé ça de près en tant que
chercheur moi je suis pas chercheur je
suis qu'un artisan mais je travaille
avec des chercheurs et d'avoir avec
Rafael au monde on a regardé un petit
peu on s'est dit bah oui pourquoi pas ça
marche ça fonctionne pourquoi faire le
danger c'est de nous couper du vivant et
ce qui nous a beaucoup pénalisé
notamment dans les 90 quand on s'est
coupé notre univers agricole et qu'on
s'est dit finalement il y a un moyen
d'acheter des produits et je ne connais
pas l'agriculteur qui le fait donc là il
y avait quelque chose dangereux mais ce
qui nous interpelle beaucoup c'est
d'abord de voir les puissances qui sont
intéressées par ce business qui est de
pas transformer de vous maîtrisez
totalement ce que doit manger un
individu c'est très dur on le
déconnectant de ce monde du vivant moi
je trouve ça dangereux et comme outil de
manipulation c'est de laisser croire que
c'est pour des causes environnementales
d'ailleurs les noms de ces sociétés sont
très intéressantes gourmet ceci etc etc
déjà il y a un piège marketing là-dedans
c'est très dangereux autant on peut
construire bien que je n'aime pas le mot
steak végétal je peux comprendre l'idée
du steak végétal et d'avoir cette
réaction de Maillard sur un poilage de
légumes pourquoi pas mais sur ces
viandes in vitro il y a un vrai danger
de manipulation et moi ça m'inquiète
beaucoup c'est surtout qu'il y a une
inconnue importante pour pour l'instant
puisque il y a peu de communication de
la part des industriels sur les
ingrédients qu'ils utilisent donc ça
pose des questions sanitaires ça pose
des questions environnementales aussi et
il y a eu il y a pas longtemps une
tribune dans le monde de la part de
scientifiques qui qui réclament un peu
de transparence là dessus pour pouvoir
évaluer les choses à peu près
correctement parce que l'essentiel des
gens qui communiquent sont ceux qui se
lance dans cette activité là vous avez
remarqué qu'il y a très très peu de
publications scientifiques à 300 les
cellules on sait pas où elles vont être
prélevées a priori le sourcing il y a
une opacité absolue mais encore une fois
moi le danger de l'alimentation c'est
pas de simplement de parler comme ça va
être truqué de gastronomie et de chef
qui aurait un rôle de d'essayer de
diriger les gens c'est transversal
c'est-à-dire que la le cadre du
questionnaire du bien manger de devenir
un mangeur et plus un consommateur ça
commence en famille bien sûr des fois
c'est un peu déséquilibré mais à l'école
dans l'apprentissage du Savoir Manger il
y a toute une étude de culture générale
que pouvait apporter dans replacer le
cours de cuisine simplement à l'école
pour y trouver le mangeur de dans 20 ans
sinon l'agriculture est-ce que fait
monsieur n'aura pas de sens parce que il
n'y aura pas de public en fait la
transition est toute trouvée pour parler
des cantines scolaires de la
restauration d'entreprise et même des
collectivités locales qui sont un levier
majeur pour réduire la part de la viande
qu'est-ce qu'on attend pour le faire il
y a un écolier sur 10 aujourd'hui qui se
voit proposer un repas végétarien par
semaine à la cantine parce que c'est
très long ça ça dérange des codes ça
dérange des cercles les tapis par
d'autres avant des centrales d'achat des
façons de travailler de replacer un
véritable artisan au cœur de la cuisine
peut-être de casser les cuisines
centrales pour se dire bah on a plutôt
intérêt de remettre et nous ça nous est
arrivé
en Touraine dans un lycée en Touraine où
là il y a le président de région qui a
accepté qu'on remette au cœur de se
lisser un artisan qui a le droit de
produire des choses qui peut acheter
dans des filières beaucoup plus courtes
etc etc évidemment on a redonné la
tractée il faut 15 ans alors regardez je
vous propose de regarder ce qui se passe
près d'Angoulême la chef Laure mardoc a
lancé cap veggie qui apprend au chef
cuisinier la végétaliser leur menu
notamment dans les cantines scolaires la
restauration collective c'est 10
millions de repas par jour en France
autant dire un levier aussi massif
kefficace pour nous apprendre à manger
mieux et autrement Alexis br Eton et
Franck Vrignon ont suivi cette
initiative soutenue par la Région
nouvelle-aquitaine le monde demain c'est
maintenant et ouvre l'appétit reportage
aujourd'hui près d'Angoulême la capitale
française de la bande dessinée pas de
feuilles blanches ni de stylo mais
casserole et cuillère dans ce lycée
professionnel
je vous réunis la chef Laure mardoc
du coup on va faire va former à la
cuisine végétarienne des chefs de
cantine scolaire je vous réunis un peu
dissipés j'ai vendu des œufs de lapin de
l'agriculture des œufs de lapin
une recette il y avait des œufs
de lapins
cet amateur d'oeuf de lapin et une
dizaine de ses collègues de la région
vont apprendre une chose importante
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas que les
saucisses dans la vie nous voici en
cuisine donc on va vous allez vous
répartir sur les plans de travail on va
faire les recettes végétariennes qu'on a
décidé de mettre en production
aujourd'hui donc voilà
allez-y à la pratique en cuisine et puis
amusez-vous bien tout est frais
aujourd'hui on fait tout en frais
ces élèves sont des chefs à l'ancienne
pourrait-on dire vient des poissons à
tous les repas ils n'ont pas beaucoup
d'idées pour travailler les légumes et
figurez-vous que le pied de brocoli est
délicieux
et en fait le truc c'est que c'est la
partie la plus la plus douce
au menu de la formation pois chiches
lentilles et haricots de toutes les
couleurs des légumineuses riches en
protéines et qui vont remplacer la
viande dans les menus des cantines
encore faut-il réussir à convaincre les
cuisiniers des galettes de haricots
rouges
c'est une recette que vous connaissez
bien ou pas du tout c'est un essai pour
moi je fais ça
[Musique]
mais pour Thierry l'enjeu de la cuisine
végétarienne est aussi ailleurs quand on
fait du végétal dans des lycées comme
j'ai une population de garçons ça
nourrit plus la poubelle que les élèves
parce que les élèves s'ils ont pas leur
viande
c'est pas leur truc que ils aiment la
viande des rugbymen ils aiment la viande
donc les végétales pour eux ils ont pas
l'impression d'avoir mangé pourtant il y
a quand même des protéines végétales qui
est le même apport que la viande et donc
voilà quoi c'est pour arriver à leur
faire comprendre ça c'est la région qui
organise cet atelier pour respecter la
loi depuis fin 2019 les établissements
scolaires français ont l'obligation de
proposer leurs élèves un menu végétarien
par semaine une disposition encore
combattue par certains à coups de
barbecue et de saucissons on a un public
féminin qui est parfois moins réticent à
aller vers ces propositions là où il y a
moins ce côté je dois bâtir mes muscles
etc et donc du coup
côté viril qui est lié à la viande et
puis il y a la question de la classe
sociale aujourd'hui les classes
populaires mangent beaucoup plus de
viande que les classes cadres donc en
fait
l'assiette elle est politique quelque
part politique et cruciale pour la
planète petit rappel 1 kg de bœuf
produit 44 fois plus de gaz à effet de
serre 15 kg de légumineuses
et selon des études officielles se
passer de viande rouge et servir trois
repas végétariens par semaine dans
toutes les cantines réduirait deux
moitiés leurs émissions de CO2 une
solution simple et immédiate rien qu'en
France la restauration collective
aujourd'hui c'est entre 3 à 4 milliards
de repas par an donc un effet massif en
fait et l'impact il va être démultiplié
aussi en restauration collective
scolaire puisque il y a un effet de long
terme c'est des jeunes qui pour toute
leur vie en fait sont peut-être adoré le
dalle lentilles ou se dire que une
quiche aux légumes ça peut faire un très
bon plat c'est un levier de
transformation de la société énorme sur
les comportements alimentaires et aussi
sur le modèle agricole alors pour
changer la donne nos chefs doivent
arriver à concocter des recettes à même
de ravir les papilles et les estomacs de
l'ensemble des jeunes Français
[Musique]
les carottes des plats comme les
traditionnels lasagnes
qui pourrait dire non au Bourguignons de
champignons
aux fajitas de haricots rouges
ça prouve qu'en collectivité on peut se
faire plaisir donc faire aussi un peu
une gastro une qualité de cuisinier en
restauration collective qui est
absolument extraordinaire
voici enfin venu le moment le plus
important de la journée
la dégustation
[Musique]
c'est très bon et même avec les
champignons comme ça ils cuisinés on
croirait même que
un petit goût de viande un petit goût de
rôti de très bon c'est pas très bon je
pense que ça c'est vendable dans un
lycée c'est un truc que les élèves ils
aimeraient
ils ont l'air de se régaler j'ai
l'impression que ça se passe plutôt bien
j'entends plutôt de bons échos donc
c'est plutôt bon en deux ans l'or a
formé plus de 500 chefs et il faut
savoir qu'ils sont maîtres en leur
cuisine ils ont le droit de proposer
plusieurs repas végétariens par semaine
ces chefs peuvent devenir des pionniers
de la transition écologique et mijoter
un avenir meilleur aux générations
futures
alors on l'aura compris la révolution se
fera par l'assiette contrairement à une
idée reçue largement relayée y compris
par le gouvernement les menus s'en
viande ne renforcent pas les inégalités
bien au contraire il rééquilibre le
repas des enfants les plus défavorisés
car ce sont eux qui mangent le plus de
viande exactement et puis de manger
moins de viande l'OMS nous le dit aussi
c'est moins de pathologie lié à la
surconsommation de la viande encore une
fois faut bien parler de ces
surconsommation parce qu'on est
consommateurs et plus mangeur nos
arrières grands-parents mettaient de
temps en temps un poulet à rôtir le
dimanche et peut-être une viande dans la
soupe de temps en temps donc ils étaient
déjà dans cette notion du flexitarisme
or que de laisser croire aux gens qu'ils
sont riches parce qu'ils mangent une
Vierge à coup bas et bien ça n'avait pas
de sens et aujourd'hui on est en train
de rééquilibrer ça et que le végétal a
un apport équilibre alimentaire plaisir
bien-être santé et ça évidemment moi je
ne peux pas parler de santé en tant
qu'artisan de plaisir et bien-être je
peux mais le tous les médecins nous le
confirme tous les médecins que je
rencontre avec tous les médecins avec
qui j'écris et bien
effectivement réduisons la viande parce
que c'est trop et là c'est une
surconsommation qui crée des pathologies
aussi toutes ces contre-vérités sur le
régime végétarien comme quoi il serait
antisocial ou nuisibles à la santé ça
vous énerve parce qu'elle avait une
bonne habitude le marqueur social
aujourd'hui même si vous êtes éleveur
c'est plus l'accès à la viande c'est à
dire que ceux qui sont revenus les plus
modestes sont ceux qui mangent trop de
viande et donc le marqueur social
aujourd'hui c'est l'accès aux fruits et
légumes c'est fondamental après moi je
voulais juste revenir sur le lien on
pense que les éleveurs ils sont juste
dans la relation d'élever leurs animaux
et moi qui suis en relation avec des
animaux d'élevage je peux vous assurer
que la relation avec les animaux est un
lien qui nous élève et puis on parle de
biodiversité sauvage et tout ça moi je
n'élève que des races locales et à
faible effectif le jour où il y a plus
d'élevage ce patrimoine disparaît avec
l'élevage et donc il faut il faut
raisons garder c'est à dire que bien sûr
qu'il faut radicalement baisser
l'élevage industriel il faut même faire
disparaître mais attention à ne pas
arriver à la neutralité carbone en 2050
il va falloir réduire les chefs faudra
réduire la consommation c'est pour ça
que les deux sujets sont intimement liés
c'est-à-dire qu'on on ne pourra pas
réduire l'activité d'élevage si on
aurait dû pas la consommation de
produits carnés et de produits laitiers
c'est pas contestable donc il faudra il
faudra réduire notre consommation de
viande mais j'insiste le marqueur social
c'est plus l'accès à la viande et ça
c'est très important il faudra appliquer
scrupuleusement le principe over Player
et on se rendra compte que seuls les
produits de très bonne qualité basé sur
des sur des pratiques agricoles qui
reviennent au fondamentaux comme nourrir
de des herbivores avec de l'herbe front
que ces produits seront accessibles à
tous les budgets et du coup on alluma
vraiment le cercle vertueux sur le
climat la biodiversité et la santé le
bon pour tous ces c'est vraiment
important et le marqueur social aussi va
vraiment c'est et puis je termine juste
là dessus mais sur un éleveur un
agriculteur c'est aussi des économies
symbiotiques des économies très à plat
qui vivent entre elles et qui arrivent à
montrer que cette relation au patrimoine
elle est absolument ce lien du vivant
une taxe sur la viande ou une TV à 0%
sur de la viande paysanne par exemple
d'élevage paysan est-ce que ce serait
une bonne idée à 0% sur la viande pour
que ce soit les distributeurs qui se
lavent dans la poche c'est c'est pas
nécessaire par contre que en plus
méfier parce que après tout le monde n'a
pas accès à l'élevage paysan il y a
aussi des gens qui habitent dans les
métropoles et il faut qu'ils puissent
avoir accès à la ferme c'est pas aussi
évident que ça sincèrement je pense
qu'il faut effectivement donner un accès
à la viande de qualité également le plus
possible également au classes sociales
défavorisées c'est la raison pour
laquelle moi je souhaite qu'on continue
cette expérimentation qui a été mise en
place par la majorité précédente donc à
laquelle j'appartiens des repas
végétariens n'allons pas d'un excès à
l'autre laissant les choses se faire
petit à petit là on a eu un exemple de
la région Aquitaine coûtait hier on
avait la possibilité d'imposer des
choses par le biais de la niche écolo
qui était présentée à l'Assemblée
nationale nous n'avons pas souhaité
aller vers ce volet obligation je vois
que les régions et la région Aquitaine
s'empare de ça c'est une excellente
chose qu'il continue à le faire et on
les aidera à aller dans ce sens mais non
posons pas les systèmes les uns aux
autres essayant de conserver des
équilibres on a vu où les excès nous
mener dans quelques domaines que ce soit
donc pour conclure la révolution viendra
des territoires savez-vous que pour
appréhender l'avenir on peut aussi
regarder le passé c'est souvent très
éclairant Charlotte et palle est donc
elle est fouillée dans les archives de
Lina et nous a exhumé ceci hier encore
sur notre coup d'oeil dans le rétro et
c'est maintenant
l'entreprise agricole ne peut plus être
gérée comme elle était gérée autrefois
il faut que le chef d'entreprise
agricole en 1964 gère son entreprise
agricole exactement de la même façon
qu'un entrepreneur qu'un industriel il
cherche actuellement quel va être la
meilleure formule pour eux qu'elles vont
être les solutions qui vont leur
permettre d'atteindre cette efficacité
sur le plan économique
différentes formules ont été proposées
soit dans le cadre des grandes
entreprises soit dans le cadre des
entreprises à structure familiale qui
semble progresser de plus en plus vers
des structures d'exploitation en commun
qui leur permettront vraisemblablement
d'arriver à cette notion de d'entreprise
de véritables entreprises agricoles
cette succession de questions
économiques techniques et aussi humaines
qu'il faut résoudre peut sembler
lointaine à la maîtresse de maison qui a
aussi ses problèmes
[Musique]
pourtant tirer les agriculteurs de
l'inconfort dans lequel ils vivent trop
souvent leur permettre de s'établir de
fonder un foyer cela concerne la Nation
toute entière les habitants des villes
comme ceux des campagnes si les jeunes
ruraux ne peuvent pas connaître une
existence meilleure et une certaine joie
de vivre il partiront de leur ferme et
c'est la production qui en souffrira
[Musique]
le consommateur en ne l'ignore pas c'est
notre meilleur client sans lui
inutile de penser à la viande
donc s'intéresser à lui c'est prendre un
certain nombre de décisions d'une part
pour qu'il ne manque pas de viande dans
l'avenir
bref plus que jamais le développement de
l'élevage conditionne notre plat de
viande quotidien
je vous sens émue alors avant de
conclure voici très vite quelques livres
pour aller plus loin l'avenir de la
planète commence dans notre assiette de
Jonathan sofran Fire qui est soulève le
rôle de l'élevage intensive dans la
crise climatique lecture que vous
pourrez compléter par son essai choc
paru en 2009 mais toujours d'actualité
faut-il manger des animaux toujours
édités à L'Olivier vous pouvez aussi
lire manger moins et mieux de viande de
Gilles Davos et Actes Sud ou comment le
moins se transforme en plus je vous
engage à vous plonger dans la fable
animalière de Lucy Rico le chant du
poulet se vide qui interroge le lien
entre ce que nous consommons et ce que
nous produisons et comment nous
composons avec ce système on appelle ça
la dissonance cognitive c'est un livre
PEL qui a été couronné par le Prix du
roman d'écologie 2021 à lire ou à relire
le très beau roman de sergent cours
nature humaine disponible chez
Flammarion enfin et pour terminer cette
remarquable en quête de Nicolas Legendre
le journaliste du Monde enquêté pendant
7 ans sur l'agrobusiness breton c'est
glaçons ces deux éditions Arthaud et
c'est dans toutes les bonnes librairies
voilà en conclusion notre bulletin de
vote se trouve aussi dans notre assiette
souvenez-vous de ce que disait Winston
Churchill mieux vaut prendre le
changement par la main avant qu'il ne
nous prennent par la gorge merci à tous
les trois merci
rendez-vous le mois prochain sur LCP
évidemment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]